it's my pleasure
now to introduce neil uh neil desvani
like there's so much to be said about
neo like he has so much great experience
uh he has served in a variety of
research and development and teaching
and executive roles in numerous
companies including symantec lifelock
twitter daisy and google you know there
are so many of them and uh
decent was actually acquired by twitter
later on and he was also cso at lifelock
and symantec's computer business unit so
without further ado i will hand this off
to to new so thank you neil for joining
us once again
thank you very much petra thank you for
the introduction and just want to make
sure everyone can hear me a-okay okay
we'll go ahead and
get started so i'm going to be talking
about uh some of the most disruptive
cyber attacks and biggest breaches that
have been taking place uh over the past
15 years there have been over 9 000 data
breaches that have occurred
and i'm going to be talking about
literally just five or six of them now
uh to talk about some of the world's
most disruptive cyber attacks i'm just
going to mention up front that you know
which ones out of these 9 000 have been
the most
disruptive is a little bit of a
subjective call some of these uh can be
measured in terms of the number of
records that have been breached some of
them can be measured in terms of the
number of organizations that have been
impacted uh but i'll go ahead and give
you a uh you know a take on on some of
some of the world's most disruptive um
and uh you know it's just one take so
let me go ahead and get started by first
talking about just some statistics
on breaches overall
over the past few years and then what
i'll do
is get into talking about some
particular cases
um
so so if we look at just the past two
years from 2019
to
the third quarter of 2021
these two
tables show
how many cyber attacks have been taking
place
and what have been the attack vectors
that have been used to get into these
organizations these particular
statistics come from the ia theft
resource center
and i will first talk about uh cyber
attacks and then i'll talk a little bit
about uh system and human errors so
of the
over 1100 cyber attacks that have taken
place just over the past
almost three years now you can see that
most of them have relied on fishing or
variants of fishing like smishing or
fishing
um
you know where everyone probably is
familiar that a phishing attack occurs
when you have some
email being sent to you by an imposter
where that person's claiming to be say
from a bank or something like this and
their goal is to try to get you to a web
page that you enter your credentials on
or to try to get you to click on a link
that results in a malware drive by
download that affects your computer
and there's various
variants of that so there's smishing
which is a sms text that attempts to do
the same uh these types of breaches also
typically involve what's called business
email compromise where the attacker's
goal is to get into your is to get into
your email so so that makes up the
overwhelming kind of majority or not the
overwhelming majority but say a majority
of them 370 out of 1100 the next most
prevalent
attack vectors that's used in cyber
attacks and breaches over the past
couple years is ransomware ransomware is
a kind of malware malicious software
where what it does is once it infects a
computer system once it's used again to
your organization
they basically will encrypt your data
with an encryption key that's only known
to the attacker and they'll send you a
ransom note saying look if you want to
get access back to your data again
you're going to have to pay us
x amount of dollars where x can be a few
hundred thousand or it could be a few
million um and i'll talk about for
instance the colonial oil pipeline
ransomware attack that occurred just
earlier this year uh in which in which
over four million dollars was was paid
to the attackers in bitcoin and then the
authorities had to work to try to get
that back
you know malware of other kinds still
continues to be a significant source of
cyber attacks and there's a number of
other causes as well
now it used to be the case many many
years ago
probably five or more years ago that a
lot of people uh and you know some
reputable companies with a research
report saying that you know 95 of cyber
attacks occur due to
uh human errors and you know
even at the time that was a view that i
didn't
i didn't quite uh
subscribe to to an extent we cannot
afford for humans to always be doing the
right things 100 of the time in order to
prevent cyber attacks we need to have
defenses that are more full tolerant and
more resilient and so in the the set of
stats from the from the ias of resource
center we can see that you know only
just uh north of 10
of breaches are now being attributed to
system and human errors with with 134
um
and
you know this while while we want to
rely on on humans to do the right things
as as often as they can i think we need
to to
be able to defend our systems even when
human humans make errors but it's it's
um it's interesting to see it's
interesting to see this that reflect in
some of the statistics
um if we go back a little bit farther in
time if we go back to
say 2003 to 2018 this is a separate
set of stats that
came from privacyrights.org and they do
have some overlap in their data sets but
but basically this graph shows causes of
breach you know over that much larger
time period and i just want to highlight
a couple things and i've i've shown this
graph maybe in one past webinar that
i've given but one thing to note is that
while it looks like hacking or malware
is the most prevalent cause right it's
got the biggest bar second bar from the
from the left here
um and that includes things like
phishing that includes malware that
includes other other cyber attacks sort
of things that's probably the category
that's most similar to what we saw on
the previous slide
one thing
that you might want to note is that if
you look at the bars for physical loss
and the bar corresponding to portable
device you know when when say media gets
lost like hard drive gets lost or a
laptop gets lost
in the case of a portable device or a
mobile device gets broken into or
something like that
you know you could see that if if if
there are
such devices and media getting lost or
stolen
those things would not end up being data
breaches if
the data
was encrypted
if the data is encrypted
uh then if you look at the state data
breach laws and in all the states that
have them they usually say that if
somebody's name and a sensitive
identifier like their social security
number or bank account number uh gets
stolen and the data was not encrypted
then it's a breach if the data is
encrypted using an encryption key only
known to the organization and that
encryption key stays protected then
there is no breach encrypted data is
just garbage to the attacker it looks
like garbage to attackers or anybody
else
and so if you combine together the bars
for physical loss and portable device
you'll see that the number of breaches
due to those clauses if you combine them
together is actually more than hacking
or malware and so by employing
encryption for data it is a very
important protection that you can use to
avoid breach even if an attacker can get
into your network in your organization
so long as they can not get at the
cryptographic keys that are used to
encrypt the data you've protected uh
you know against against an all-out
breach basically what encryption does is
if you have a lot of sensitive data when
you encrypt it
what it does is it reduces the problem
from protecting the large large amount
of data to protecting the much smaller
encryption keys that are used to encrypt
the data and it makes the problem more
tractable so in any case i thought i'd
show this stat as well but you know
beyond beyond physical loss and portable
device uh issues hacking our malware is
then the next most significant cause and
we're going to be talking about uh now a
whole bunch of uh different breaches now
for those of you that um
that that know me or have heard me speak
before uh you know i i have given uh
talks on on breaches before
um and what i'm going to do in this talk
is focus on more of some of the
big big recent breaches but there have
been some pretty darn disruptive
breaches that have taken place in the
past and i'm just going to mention a
couple of them
so if we go back to 2015 the us
government's office of personnel
management which is really the agency
that serves as like the chief human
resource agency
for most government agencies there's
hundreds of government agencies and they
don't all have
an hr department of their own they they
also don't do all of the background
checks that you need to get a government
job
on their own they would all rely on the
office of personal management what
happened in 2015 is that
a set of attackers took advantage of the
fact that opm had highly under-invested
in their own security and did not have
mitigations like multi-factor
authentication in place
and the attackers were able to break
into opm systems and steal
background check and very sensitive
information
for over 20 million government employees
and contractors you know even when going
for very sensitive jobs uh within the
government you've got to fill out this
form called sf-86 and it has data
centered not just about you including
your social security number but it has
that information for your family your
friends your relatives your neighbors
they all get interviewed those
interviews are in those files there's uh
psychological tests that people have to
sometimes go through they sometimes need
to go through polygraph tests lie
detector tests and all of that data is
is you know was at the office of
personnel management including uh over
five million fingerprint records um what
the attackers did is they they broke
into opm
and they stole that data so if you're a
foreign nation-state adversary and let's
say you want to you know mint spies in
the country
you know all that data
you know can be used all that metadata
can be used to
uh to to try to get a spy a job at a
government agency and then you know then
conduct an insider attack i mean it's a
huge amount of data and basically when
all that data was stolen it also posed
risks for
you know
dia and other government agents just all
around the world what had happened was
even though the cia the cia of course
the central intelligence agency they
they're one of the few agencies that
maintain their own personal records in
their own database but what happened
when this breach occurred is that you
know let's say that you're you're you're
a foreign uh nation state and you want
to try to get a sense of who are the cia
spies in your country what you can do is
you can
look at
the list of all the names and aliases
that are on file at your own state
department and you can subtract out
the data that was stolen in the opm
breach right because those are all kind
of the known government agencies
employees not including the cia and you
can see who's left on that list well
that's your set of candidate cia spots
so when there was an investigation of
this particular breach um
you know by
uh the the us house of representatives
as per this house oversight majority
report one of one of the statements in
their uh by a high-level official said
that the impact of that breach cannot be
overstated nor will it ever be fully
known and basically it's set uh you know
the us government and various agencies
back i mean a couple it's going to take
you know decades to recover from this
breach to the extent because you know
for instance when somebody's fingerprint
gets stolen
sure you can change your name uh you
know some agencies could even change
your social security number not many
but once somebody steals your
fingerprint you can't exactly change
your fingerprint so if an attacker
wanted to break into biometric systems
that are used to authenticate people uh
or come up with you know wax
fingerprints as you might have seen in
like mission impossible you know this is
exactly the kind of thing on a steel so
so i i would say
you know subjectively i i believe that
uh
that has been one of the most
destructive breaches
that have occurred over time
the next breach that i'm going to talk
about is the yahoo breach
back in 2016 yahoo had announced that it
had actually gotten breached back in
2013 and 2014
uh and pretty much
every single yahoo email account
all three billion of them got
compromised the attackers initially
gotten to yahoo through a combination of
spearfishing and malware but one of the
things that they did
is they reverse engineered
yahoo's cookie generations and so for
all of us that use websites and have
some technical background in how
websites are built we know that you know
you go to the front page of a website
you enter your username and password but
once that username and password is
checked or authenticated then the
website gives you a authentication
cookie that's sent to your browser and
then it's really that authentication
cookie that goes back and forth between
the browser and the web servers that
authenticate you so that you don't have
to type in your username and password
onto every page because
http the fundamental protocol that's
used to run interactions on the web is a
quote-unquote stateless protocol it
doesn't maintain state so it really
relies on this authentication cookie to
maintain the state that you know the
person actually
successfully logged in but what happened
in the yahoo breach of breach is is that
the the the attackers uh suspected
russian attackers and by the way let me
mention that the office of personnel
management breach was suspected to have
been conducted by uh a chinese uh funded
uh attacker the yahoo reach was
you know was suspected to have taken
place by four
uh four russian attackers two xfsv
agents fsv is kind of the new kgb if you
will
and what those attackers did after they
initially got in and and took over some
accounts for some employees
is they they reverse engineered
yahoo's cookie generation scheme and so
the idea is that if you can figure out
how a website generates its
authentication cookies
then you can log in at will without a
password
into any account
only knowing the account name or email
address and that is exactly what the
what the attackers did so pretty much
all three billion yahoo accounts
were
compromised and the russian attackers
that conducted that attack what they did
is they
uh targeted a few thousand
um
you know diplomats ambassadors uh
members of the russian press like all
kinds of folks that were of interest
um and so so the yahoo breach
uh still today is the largest breach in
the history of the internet as measured
by the number of accounts that were
breached
um this breach was also disclosed
while yahoo was getting
what in the process of getting acquired
by verizon and verizon and yahoo had
originally agreed on a price of about
4.8 billion for the company and uh
verizon dropped that price by 350
million so there was also some pretty
significant financial impact but you
could imagine just the the loss of
privacy to every any and every
uh user that um
that that was using a yahoo email
account so i would also
uh put forth that that's probably one of
the most disruptive uh reaches of all
time
um there's a few other breaches that i
will i will talk about um you know i'm
going to talk about solar winds and i'm
going to talk about the colonial oil
pipeline uh breaches from from just the
past
year uh in more detail but the one
breach that i want to comment on
um
you know
just kind of at a high level is the the
equifax breach of 2017 equifax uh is one
of the us's uh three major credit
agencies the other are experian and
transunion
um
and you know they've all experienced
breaches uh at some level um transunion
probably least impacted uh experian more
so in equifax
basically had the largest financial
identity breach um of all time back in
2017 where they were running a unpatched
apache strut server that they'd used to
as part of middleware in terms of
developing
uh some of their software
and um while there was a um
you know a very
uh critical vulnerability
uh in march of 2017 that apache had let
the world know about
the team at equifax have not patched
that vulnerability in time and the
attackers
used it to
break into
you know one server initially
and they were able to over a period of
months
steal
financial identity information
for approximately half of the country
um you know there's about 300 or 340
million consumers in the us depending
upon how you want to measure and the
attackers got out with 145 million uh
names social security numbers dates of
birth driver's license numbers
and uh let me just mention that while
when that breach occurred in in the
press
uh there was a lot of talk about the
apache struts vulnerability and the
entire the entire breach was kind of
getting blamed on that that one
um
vulnerability and in fact uh you know
when when there was a congressional
hearing about that breach i mean the the
former ceo at equifax even tried to pin
it on you know one employee who was
expected to patch that it turned out
that the that the email telling them to
patch was actually sent to that person's
manager never got forwarded on anyhow i
think you know there's this whole
business about trying to bring breaches
on humans but what if you're running an
organization of any reasonable size and
you've got thousands tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of servers you
know you can't rely or expect to rely on
humans to patch each and everything
exactly right you know that number of
machines some number of machines are
going to be down some machines being
serviced and you need to really have a
scalable automated way of rolling out
patches and really only page people when
there's some corner case if some machine
didn't get passed whatever so in any
case equifax unfortunately didn't have
that sophisticated system in place
and um you know the the media discussion
was all about this apache strut's
vulnerability but you know while there
can be initial compromises and initial
initial compromises and many
organizations you know that in and of
itself that one thing shouldn't
necessarily lead to such a large breach
there were a whole bunch of other things
that went wrong in order for that breach
to take place so for instance um one of
the issues at equifax was that they did
not have a computer network that was
segmented or broken up into as many
zones as needed and so the idea is that
you know you should fully expect that
attackers at some point are going to
compromise part of your network but that
doesn't necessarily mean that it needs
to lead to a super big breach and so in
equifax's case the attackers were able
to get into you know one server
initially due to this uh apache
strengths vulnerability
but uh there were a whole bunch of other
things that were wrong as well so once
the attackers got in they were able to
get access to over 60 databases because
the network was
quote unquote flat it was not broken up
into zones it was not segmented
that was one problem another problem was
that there were
unencrypted
database passwords
sitting in configuration files in
different parts of the equifax network
and the environment and so you know if
you take
um not only the unpatched apache start
server but if you take
the uh lack of network segmentation the
fact that there were unencrypted
credentials for extensive databases
sitting around you know
you take all these factors combined and
that is really what led to
the huge breach of half of the country's
social security numbers and whatnot
approximately half
so you know i'll mention that you know
what i'll do now i'll also now comment
on a couple other breaches talk about
the solarwinds breach and the colonial
pipeline breach in a in a little bit
more detail but one other breach that i
want to chat about in in more detail is
a breach at a breach at facebook and by
the way let me mention
that facebook has had a whole string of
security incidents over time not all of
them have been breaches some you know
norfolk for breach as part of the legal
environment there's got to be someone's
name and some sensitive identifiers got
them stolen
but facebook has had
many security incidents and issues that
have not been formal data breaches but
have been hacks of other kinds and you
know i i list a whole bunch of these um
you know on a couple slides i mean it
starts uh you know as early as 2007 and
in 2008 for instance facebook rolled out
a change where they were putting out a
new version of the site and they
inadvertently revealed the birth dates
of over 80 million
of their users even though those users
said please do not share my birthday
that was an example of a of a
of a software bug you know that led to
a security incident
um
you know there there have been a number
of these security incidents over time
i'm going to comment about just two of
them um many folks may have heard back
in
2016 in kind of the
the time or around the aftermath of the
us election that um
facebook
suffered a
uh
you know a hack due to a third party of
theirs called cambridge analytica
um
in which
uh
you know cambridge analytica abused a
whole bunch of information
uh
from facebook profiles facebook as a
social network one of the things that
they
had done in order to achieve the
completely amazing wild widespread
growth
is that they had you know even going
back to 2007 and 2008 they had tons of
people adopting the service setting up
profiles connecting with friends
um
and one of the things that they that
they that they did as did many other
social networks is they allowed
third-party developers to write
applications
on facebook that would provide
additional functionality to the website
some of some of the applications might
be games that allow people to
you know play games together with other
members of their social network um you
know many many other apps tons of tons
of creativity
and innovation um
that said that said if you were a
facebook application developer um
when a user installed your app um
those
third-party developers would get access
information to information about your
profile they would get access to your
name your birth date which which posts
you've liked um who all your friends are
and
what what what had uh occurred is um
there was back in 2014 and 2015 there
was a research by the name of alexander
kogan at the university of cambridge
that had built an application called
this is your digital life and he was
interested in studying people's
psychological profiles and so he
released an application that was a
personality test
and they they had paid a few hundred
thousand people using amazon mechanical
turk to install that application and
conduct the personality test
um and and while there were only a few
hundred thousand
people
that installed the personality test and
and did the personality test because of
the fact
that
the way that the facebook apis for
third-party developers used to work is
that those third-party developers would
get access not just to
the few hundred thousand people who
installed the app they didn't just get
access their profiles but they could get
access to a list of all their all their
friends
um and so as a result um there were
about 87 million there was data that was
gathered on 87 million people
and what happened is cambridge analytica
bought that application and all the data
on and cambridge analytica provided a a
service to
politicians
that allowed them to advertise
to voters on facebook
and
the
the the data from the profile
as well as
what people liked were used to advertise
uh to them
the problem with all of this is that
when alexander kogan developed this this
is digital life app they developed it
and they stored data about people in
violation of facebook's terms and
conditions
um and as a result when that data got
bought and was then abused
uh to target users and and and
you know influence uh you know their
their votes um it was it was a
significant it was a significant issue
um
in addition around you know a couple
years prior to to the election even
starting
there were
russian
actors
that
mounted disinformation and
misinformation campaigns on facebook
using both organic content and ads
so so in a in a in kind of a separate
distinct
uh issue
um
you know there were approximately 126
million
uh folks that were exposed
to organic content that that russian
actors at a agency called the russian
internet agency
um i'm sorry the internet russia
research agency uh had created uh as
what are typically referred to as
quote-unquote active measures when when
um a government's trying to uh kind of
interfere here and so basically there
were 126 million americans that were
exposed to all this content not only
just content but also ads on this slide
i show an example there were about 3 500
ads and by the way these stats come from
facebook's own investigation of the of
the incident um
so so there were 11 million americans
that were exposed to these 3 500 ads
i've shown a couple of these ads in
which
um
you know hillary clinton was was
targeted and uh you can see the number
of uh impressions and clicks and the the
budget and russian rubles that were
applied for these other ads so there's a
lot more data
behind what happened here
but uh you know in 2017
um the the us intelligence community had
done an assessment and they issued a
report where basically they said
um you know vladimir putin
had ordered an influence campaign aimed
at the presidential election and that
and their goal was to undermine
faith in the democratic process
denigrate
uh hillary clinton and then harmon
electability uh so
this was a very very significant
incident you know facebook and its
technology and its social network
has the potential to do so much good
in connecting the world together and
connecting
everyone together
unfortunately uh the technology is still
fairly fairly new
and unfortunately was susceptible to
abuse
um
both by companies like cambridge
analytica as well as um you know
governments and let me mention that
there you know this isn't just a a
russia usa thing um
there's many many countries where where
other politicians would hire cambridge
analytica
to
help get them votes and target voters
and influence those that whose votes
could be
votes could be uh
changed
um so so mark zuckerberg in 2017 this
was you know nine months after the
intelligence community assessment had
been done he put out this quote saying
that he he apologized he apologized um
and asked for forgiveness
to do better
um because
the facebook platform was used to divide
people
rather than rather than bring them
together and uh you know facebook has
you know put in more work uh
perhaps even a considerable amount of
work
to
uh
help prevent their platform from being
abused
but you know if you look at the you know
the news um
there
there's still much more work to be done
um so in any case um
i'm going to just talk about one more
one more facebook incident uh in 2008 so
facebook by the way after the cambridge
analytica incident and after all that
they had took significant steps to lock
down their apis so that third party
developer
third-party developers could not abuse
data from profiles and such things
um
but the service uh facebook as a company
has so much data that if you're in say a
nation state adversary and you still
even after they did all their lockdowns
um you know say uh you know up to 2017.
all the lockdowns of 2017. you're let's
say if you were a nation-state attack
and you still wanted to get data on tens
of millions of profiles how do you go
about and do it
well let me talk about one uh
one one breach that occurred uh due to a
piece of functionality called view as in
facebook so if you have a facebook
profile um when you see your profile
regularly
um you
pretty much have full access to profile
you can all edit almost everything on it
and you see everything on it um and if
you're interested in seeing what your
profile looks like to a visitor um then
you can click this view as visitor
button and then all of the editing
buttons and whatnot disappear and you
just see the profile
and the data that you have chosen to
expose to the rest of the world so this
view has features is is to a large
extent a privacy feature that lets you
see
what your profile looks like to the rest
of the world unfortunately
there were three
software security vulnerabilities
that
were used to
get not just read access but full read
write access to tens of millions of
profiles and and facebook published a
blog post a very good blog post on um
how the breach occurred when they
completed their investigation and they
found that the root causes were really
three such vulnerabilities first
what happened is that in the view as
feature
there was
a widget
that would allow people
to wish their friends a happy birthday
uh but
there was a bug which
allowed
the viewer of a particular profile to
not just wish somebody a happy birthday
but
let them post a video
so
uh
you know that's kind of like a write
capability as opposed to a read
capability to allow them to post a video
second thing that went wrong is that
there was a new version of this video
uploader that came out
in july 2017 where it
generated
um
you know an access token that gave
uh the user kind of full permissions of
the facebook mobile app instead of a
more limited set of privileges and the
third thing that went wrong and this was
really the kicker is that when the video
uploader
appeared as part of the view as
it generated an access token
not for somebody to view the profile
but
it allowed the person that was viewing
the profile it generated an access token
that allowed them to have full read
write capability to the profile so so
think about that um you know you're
viewing somebody's facebook profile and
there's a bug in the site which lets you
not just read the profile but access the
profile as if you were the person
themselves whose profile you're viewing
so so that's how that breach occurred
and you know facebook they had seen
that
there were tens of millions of profiles
that were being scraped and whatnot and
the the they were just seeing tons of
data that was anomalous
and they had they had reset 80 million
profiles they had done effectively a a
password reset um for 80 million
profiles access token resets um because
they wanted to stop that activity from
taking place and and you know every time
that they do that they're privying
themselves of the revenue and the ads
and stuff because a lot of those people
that got logged out may never log back
in again because a lot of people forget
the password and whatnot so in any case
um you know that was the facebook
viewers breach was due mostly to
software vulnerabilities
and um let me let me pause here
um what i'm going to do is i'm going to
talk about the solarwinds uh hack and
talk about the colonial pipeline uh
breach and then i'll talk about the root
causes from all these breeds and really
really summarize synthesize the things
that we've learned let me pause here for
a second and take a question or two
thank you neil um we got a bunch of
questions and if anybody else would like
to ask anything feel free to use the q a
box a number of questions were actually
asking about the defenses and i know
like you will get to that later on in
the presentation but maybe let me uh
bring one question that is connected to
the mega breaches and the question is
like if you see any like trends like a
number of breaches and their size like
are they increasing like is there more
money involved like what do you see from
your perspective as like the expert in
the industry and like is there any way
how we can predict what will be
happening in the next few years
sure so first of all the number of
breaches
have been increasing if
we look at just uh you know data from
the idea theft resource center the
number of breaches in just the first
three quarters of this year has already
exceeded the number of breaches last
year
so at least over the past year there has
been an increase in the number of
breaches one of the things that i'm
going to talk about is that
the the the root causes of these
breaches there's a fairly small set um
of under 10 root causes i'd say that
three of those root causes are
managerial
and six of those root causes are
technical i'll just provide the the one
sentence answer but i'll return to it
the six technical root causes of
breaches so you know if you're if you're
a head of security for a company you
have to deal with tons of compliance and
tons of regulations and you have
hundreds upon hundreds of check boxes
that you need to satisfy in order to to
be compliant with pci or hipaa or all
these different um security standards
like 27 000 whatever happens to be but
there you know when you look at all
these breaches there are really just six
technical route clauses for all these
breaches they are
phishing and account takeover as number
one
uh malware number two
software vulnerabilities number three
unencrypted data number four
third-party compromise and abuse number
five also called supply chain security
these days uh in the aftermath of the
solarwinds attack and whatnot and then
finally inadvertent employee mistakes
separate from fishing phishing has been
such a huge category it just deserves a
huge category of its own but there are
other uh innovative employee mistakes
that i made those are really the six
technical route closets so the guidance
is to focus on those encounter measures
for those and try to achieve compliance
as a as
yes and from what i'm hearing it seems
like a lot of that is controllable right
because i i'm like getting a sense from
some of the questions that this is like
something that comes in and it's very
hard to protect yourself against that
yes so the overwhelming majority of
breaches
are
preventable you know um for instance if
we just go back
and uh you know look at um you know the
slide slide number
uh one or two here let me bring this up
um
you know there are some attacks where
for instance an attacker comes up with a
completely new vulnerability and
leverages a completely new vulnerability
that nobody has ever seen before
so i'm trying to bring up slide number
14 here
um
and it's uh you know not getting along
with me i don't know if petra if you
were somebody on your i think it should
be live a number of breaches by attack
vector uh it should be live yes oh you
see that okay great okay
uh good so so so that that particular
slide if you look at it the number of
zero day there there's one line here for
zero day attack right under cyber
attacks the out of the over 1100
breaches that have taken place the
number of breaches that are due to kind
of zero-day vulnerabilities
vulnerabilities that the software
manufacturer never knew about
that's completely newly discovered only
two
only two i'd say so i'd say that out of
these 1100 beaches most of them are
preventable there may be a few really
just a few can count on a single hand
where there was some new vulnerability
that was taken advantage of that just
the world has never
been aware before so so they are all
they are all preventable so let me move
forward let me talk about solarwinds and
then i'll put up a slide with some with
some defenses and i'll
uh work to finish uh on time here
um
now let's see here uh what's interesting
is i am can everyone see the solarwinds
slide now
yes yes yes great okay good so so what's
interesting here is that you guys can
see this live for some reason it's not
popping up but i'll just i'll just i'll
just talk about the slide from memory so
what happened in
mid-december
of last year mid-december 2020
is that um there was there was a hack at
a company called solarwinds
solarwinds
um is a it
uh company
that has over 300 000 customers
and they have tons of products and
services that help manage
companies
help help
organizations manage their information
technology and also some that help to
manage their security
what happened is there was a foreign
nation-state adversary attacker
suspected russian
where
they
not only broke into solar winds
but what they did is they infiltrated
the software development pipeline for
one of their products solarwinds orion
and what they did is they inserted a
back door into that product so that what
they could do is they could issue a
malicious code update you know
it's good to patch your systems and
whatnot but basically they injected a
back door which allowed the attackers to
publish a code update
of whatever they chose
and because solarwinds was used by so
many organizations
the attackers use that that
vulnerability
uh
in the solarwinds product to break into
nine
or more government agencies including
the us department of treasury the us
department of commerce the department of
homeland security
um
and over a hundred private sector
companies
this is called a supply chain attack
because
um
it's called supply chain attack because
the solar wind software is one of the
suppliers uh that many of these are the
organizations used and it was used as
the vector to to get in
um so there's a lot of uh you know
interesting technical detail around the
malware that the attacker is injecting
now the way that the attackers by the
way broke into solarwinds was as per you
know there was kind of like nothing new
there um you know based on the
hypotheses and the investigation that
the ways the attackers got in was pretty
straightforward but what they did after
that was sophisticated
um
and
so
this has resulted in
pretty significant impact so earlier
this year
joe biden
president biden issued a executive
order
that directed a whole bunch of other
agencies in the government to take steps
to vet
any companies and
the software of companies
that sell
and service the federal government
this is probably the most significant
action that any president u.s president
has ever taken when it has come to cyber
security
and uh i i think it's uh hopefully going
to be a very positive positive step
um
but but that's pretty much what happened
in the in the solar winds attack um the
the attackers
well based on the investigations for
instance when they broke into the
department of justice
um their goal was to get access to their
emails they they read emails of like
three different 3000 different email
accounts in the department of justice
the the full impact of this
hack by the way is is fully yet to be
determined because even just two weeks
ago
there was data that came out
saying that
really
one of the other things that the the
russian hackers were interested in is
you know what is what has been the us
sanctions policy based on the data that
they accessed the attackers were also
able to get access to microsoft source
code
they were able to steal attack tools
from fire iron man yet and so by the way
this attack was discovered by fire
mandiant in mid december 2020. uh
firearm indians one of the most
sophisticated forensics teams in the
world they regularly help other
companies
identify when they've been breached how
big the breach has been and help them
contain the breach um and and you know
really just some of the best experts in
the world
and and they're the ones that identified
this attack against solar winds and they
found that that some of their own attack
tools some of their own penetration
testing tools had been stolen in the
attack as well
so so so really this has been a this was
a you know certainly
uh i i think uh i i think it's a good
candidate for one of the world's most
disruptive cyber cyber attacks
um the next one i'm going to talk about
is the colonial oil pipeline
so what happened earlier this year
is that um there's a you know a company
by the name of uh colonial pipeline
they're one of the largest oil pipelines
in the country
and
they um
they they use a vpn
um
and what the attackers did is they found
a password on the dark web
for one of the employees of
the organization that they used to break
into the vpn and then they infected the
vpn
uh the virtual private network uh with
with malware uh in particular with
ransomware and basically said look we're
we've encrypted the data on a whole
bunch of your systems if you don't pay
us um you know a whole bunch of bitcoin
i think it was 80 or so bitcoin or 70 or
so bitcoin i don't know uh it basically
amounted about four million dollars in
ransom
and uh they said look if you don't pay
us this uh we're not getting your data
back so colonial pipeline pretty much
they they were unsure of what systems
are still under their control what
systems still are not under the control
they're running an oil pipeline they
have no idea what the attackers
intentions actually are and so they
pretty much shut down the oil pipe this
did result in an increase in oil prices
and it was
probably the first major ransomware
attack that
was interpreted to be a threat to
national security at the time you know
nobody knew who was conducting this
attack turned out it was a cyber
criminal group that just wanted to make
money but basically that particular
cyber criminal group came out and and
said hey look we are we are not the
russian government we are not funded by
the russian government um we're just
trying to make some money but you could
imagine
that the response to this kind of attack
would be would be very different if it
was say more than just a group of
organized cyber criminals trying to make
some money
in any case the authorities did go after
the attackers they were able to you know
while to an extent like bitcoin supposed
to be untraceable or whatnot um the
authorities did go after
the bitcoins and actually recovered
most of them right the majority of it 60
or whatever out of the 70 or whatever i
remember the actual numbers but bottom
line this was a you know certainly
a very disruptive cyber attack and to an
extent it has resulted in elevating how
significant ransomware is as a threat
not only to the country but to the world
there was a gathering at the white house
uh where where
cyber security in general was getting
talked about some very large companies
uh like microsoft and google attended
um
and there there was also an
international gathering over 60
countries uh to not the white house but
at another location to talk about
ransomware right so it's just you know
as somebody who's kind of um you know
ascended through the field mostly as a
technologist it's just super interesting
to see
the the impacts of of of these of these
cyber attacks so so so basically to
defend against ransomware you should
deploy
um
you know first of all make sure you have
backups you know so that if an attacker
encrypts your source code or encrypts
important company information or
whatever
you know you want to be able to get that
back so back it up back it up ideally
offline because a lot of sophisticated
ransomware this these days also goes
after
they basically go after your encrypted
uh they go after your backups too so
once they break in if you have like
backups in the cloud uh you know uh
they will they will target those and
crypt those and take those offline
you've got to also have offline backups
and you've got to regularly test your
backup procedures because there's some
stat i read a while back like 50 of
companies that even have backup
processes in place are not able to
successfully recover from those backups
um
you know when they need to like in the
midst of an attack so you've got to
quarterly be testing your restoration
processes in addition it's super
important to have strong anti-malware
defense uh very often attackers will
generate new variants of ransomware or
malware that have just never been seen
before so you cannot relate rely on a a
virus anti-virus product that just lies
on signatures and whatnot
so anyhow those are those are some
ransomware defenses that you should keep
in mind
um thinking about all these breaches and
especially some of the most disruptive
ones you know one one question to ask is
what have been the root causes so so
typically
um managerial root causes for breach
include the failure to one prioritize
cyber security number two failure to
invest in cyber security properly for
instance
when the office of personnel management
uh had gotten broken into they were only
spending three million dollars a year on
their security when even the department
of agriculture was spending more than 70
million at the time so there was a
super under investment in security now
even once you prioritize cyber security
and once you invest in it
it is important to successfully execute
on cyber security initiatives so for
instance at opm they were trying to roll
out two-factor authentication they were
trying to roll out better web proxies
they were trying to do all kinds of
things which they didn't successfully
execute on any of it in time to prevent
the breach
when it comes to technical requests of
reach as i mentioned the the the top six
are here um for phishing and account
takeover um you know using multi-factor
authentication is super super important
i would suggest using hardware security
keys like those that have been rolled
out by yubikey or google's titan where
basically uh to log in you need more
than just a username and password you
you know
instead of relying on a six-digit code
you know by the way attackers can set up
phishing websites that'll ask not just
for the username and password but ask
for the six digit or eight-digit code
too so even though when you use you know
such multi-factor authentication with a
code being sent to your cell phone or
using a mobile authenticator app you can
you can still have employees that get
duped
one of the only non-fishable defenses is
to use a hardware security key
that you stick into your usb port
like a yubikey where there's a secret on
it that's associated with the user
that's protected with tamper resistant
hardware
when google deployed
yubikeys back in 2017 even though google
is regularly under nation state attack
they have not successfully had a
phishing attack or an account takeover
attack of that kind um
for four years after the deployment of
harvard security keys even though they
are regularly regularly regularly under
attack from nation states
so i'd say that you know that's kind of
kind of the best defense next best
defense is to use say a mobile
authenticator app or a dedicated
hardware device that gives you those
keys um you know the next uh root clause
of breach uh that i'll talk about is is
now where important to have good
anti-malware defense
um
software vulnerabilities are also a very
significant cause of breach as we saw in
the facebook case from the ui's
vulnerability in 2018. it's important to
test yourself to first of all before
even testing your software to design
security in to your development
processes do security design reviews uh
then also do testing use static and
dynamic analysis tools sas and das
there's a whole bunch of technologies
here
that by the way don't have enough time
to cover in this very short webinar but
we go into in tons of detail in our in
our courses um you know whether it be
the cyber security executive strategy
course or whether it be securing
protecting web applications mobile
security we have tons of courses that go
through uh this stuff in a lot of detail
but you know for some of the other
um
for some of the other
root causes as well there are a whole
bunch of defenses that you can you can
employ uh for unencrypted data well
encrypt the data and encrypt the data
not only at rest not only in transit a
lot of cloud providers also allow you to
encrypt data while it's being in use one
of the traditional challenges is that
you know if you have uh if an attacker
breaks into a system and gets admin or
root credentials it's kind of like game
over they have access to the full
general purpose processor and all memory
and all registers and so what you can do
is in instead rely on secure enclaves
which use a separate dedicated
co-processor uh to access and unencrypt
data and a separate dedicated memory to
process unencrypted data so in any case
i'm just giving you a sampling of some
of the root causes of breaches and some
of the technologies they can use to
fight them
um
you know i i you know this this next
slide here
you know lists out a lot of those
defenses that i've talked about but let
me just go ahead and summarize that
coming up at the end of time
this slide shows
uh
a lot of the
biggest
uh quote-unquote most disruptive
breaches that have occurred over time
and and what have been the learnings
from them i've been talking a little bit
about uh each of them uh as we've been
as we've been going through
um but but here's a slide that
summarizes it in some cases you know an
organization did not use multi-factor
authentication in some cases the
organization did not invest in other
cases uh the organization had a software
vulnerability a third party software
vulnerability in the case of effects
that was not patched
in
facebook's case there were first-party
software vulnerabilities that simply
hadn't been found by their own
development teams but were found by
attackers uh in the case of solarwinds
um you know they were they were
infiltrated and their build pipeline was
was taken over uh and used to insert
backdoors so you've gotta you've gotta
both protect your company as well as you
know
solarwinds ceo
uh
you know the new ceo he basically
talked about having multiple build
pipelines and you know if you do those
heterogeneously then even though an
attacker might be able to break into one
it may not be able to break into the
other and compare the output of all
these pipelines so so in any case uh
this side slide summarizes overall let
me let me let me summarize and conclude
uh the guidance that i like to give is
that as somebody who's a scientist an
engineer by background i feel that
should focus on addressing the root
causes of these breaches from a
technical perspective uh you know the
security field is full of tons of
marketing and tons of noise and there's
always some new cool defense against the
latest zero day attack but most of these
breaches have not been taking place due
to kind of the most sophisticated
zeroties that that they're occurring for
reasons and root causes for which we do
have defenses for many of them
scientifically effectively shown to be
um strong very strong um
you know and and others where were where
perhaps you know there's good defenses
we just need to make them better most of
these breaches are preventable they're
interested in more information uh you
know please feel free to reach out to me
or or
follow me on twitter um if we have time
i'd be happy to take say one question
uh and and or you know or two if we do
have time but i hope that folks have
found
the information in this webinar useful
um and i'd encourage you to also check
out some of stanford's courses because
as these breaches are uh mostly
preventable there's a lot of uh you know
technology and process that you can find
uh knowledge about in our courses to
help protect your organization and
protect yourself so i hope you've
enjoyed it and uh look forward to taking
a question or two
thank you so much so much neil i think
this was uh very insightful
so let me try and only do a bunch of
questions let me pick one like how would
you suggest companies prioritize these
defenses like do you think there is some
you know some basis that each company
even the smallest startup needs to have
uh like you know do you have any
recommendation there
yeah so my my recommendation uh say for
the for the largest companies is that
cyber security is an issue
that has to be discussed
um
i would encourage
ceos or ctos to you know in a large
company to hire
a chief information security office um
and make them accountable for security
but realize that security
uh you know the buck stops with the ceo
and the board in the target breach from
2013 uh the ceo was fired in addition to
the cso the board was sued so so for the
big companies you got to start at the
top and i'd say you know even at the
other end of the spectrum at a startup
you know you don't necessarily want to
put in you know steel defenses when you
don't have enough to defend yet but i
would say that like if you're erecting a
house um you know and you want it to be
secure down the line one thing you could
do is you could put in a steel door
frame even though
you may just put in a wood door
initially then when your startup grows
and is uh you know becomes big enough of
a target you can then at least put the
steel door in the steel door frame um
but the you know putting in a steel door
front door frame after the fact is
really hard so i'd encourage you to take
the steps to set up the right framework
so that you can secure yourself and your
products as you become more and more
valuable
thank you so much
i think this was a wonderful summary uh
thank you so much for joining us thank
you all the attendees for you know
spending this hour with us i hope you
found it as insightful as i did and you
know i think you will have a great
october day and also i have a great rest
of the year see you soon bye
you